Es la primera vez que pasa en la
historia de Estados Unidos un gran
Jurado nunca había acusado a un ex
presidente de Estados Unidos hasta ahora
los cargos específicos contra Donald
Trump aún no se han hecho públicos pero
se cree que se refieren a un presunto
fraude empresarial Entonces qué ocurrirá
a continuación se le notificará que
viaje a Nueva York para entregarse uno
de sus abogados dice que la expectativa
es que sea procesado el próximo martes
será fichado y se le leerán sus derechos
le dará la oportunidad de comparecer
ante el tribunal no va a ser detenido
ahora será fichado lo que significa que
se le tomarán las huellas dactilares se
le tomará una foto policial pero
ciertamente no le pondrán las esposas no
va a ser puesto en una celda con la
población general
la acusación es solo el principio de un
largo proceso
van a pasar muchos meses
es incluso aproximadamente un año antes
de que un juicio si haya uno siga
adelante y por lo tanto estamos muy
lejos de que Donald Trump realmente
sufra consecuencias duraderas por sus
acciones
hay una gran preocupación por la
seguridad ya que Trump se enfrenta ahora
a una posible pena de prisión se han
instalado barricadas fuera del edificio
del capítulo de Estados Unidos ya que
las autoridades temen que se repita lo
sucedido el 6 de enero de 2021 Mientras
tanto la candidatura de Trump a la
reelección sigue en